مرحبا تتنافس مختلف القنوات المغربيه على
جذب المشاهد بالتطرق الى عدد متنوع من
القبائل الاجتماعيه ضمن باقي من الاعمال
الدراميه والكوميديه الجديده بمناسبه
الشهر رمضان من بينها اعمال لقيت نجاح
كبير في المواسم الماضيه واخرى جديده ابرز
هذه الاعمال مسلسل ديرو انديه كوميديا ولا
دراما كل عمل كتبقى عنده الخصوصيه ديالو
كتبقى عنده المتعه ديال الاشتغال فيه
كنشتغلو كيكون الخدمه كبيره
الحلقات ديالك يعني تتحول ما امكن انه
يكون نقي ميه في المئه
وخاضع بزاف ديال ديال الشروط اللي تتماشى
مع المبادئ ديال العائلات المغربيه في
الدراما
عليهم نيسوار
ديال الحوايج اللي كيع اونوك القصه في
السيتكوم كيكون ذاك الشيء خفيف
وبالزربه خصك
تبث الحضور ديالك وتخلي هذيك البصمه في
واحد القالب اللي هو كوميدي وخفيف ظريف
العمل بالديره النيه بعد الانجازات
المشرفه اللي قدمها المنتخب المغربي لكره
القدم في منافسات كاس العالم الاخيره حيث
كان اسم العمل الشركاء وتم تغييره احتفالا
بما قدموا اللاعبون المغاربه في مونديال
قطر من جهه وتاكيدا على الاثر الايجابي
لمفهوم النيه على حياه الافراد بشكل عام
من جهه اخرى رغم انه وصل للمغرب متاخر
هو نوع من الانتاج بالنسبه للمشاهد
المغربي هي فرجه المغربي لا يفرق بين
والمسلسل كل واحد عنده صعوبه ديالو تمثيل
عنده صعوبته والغناء كذلك عنده صعوبه
ماكينه حتى شي حاجه ساهله كل حاجه خصك
تركز عليها تعطيها وقتها تعطيها تعطيها
احساسها لان حتى التمثيل احساسيتيش بذاك
الشخصيه اللي انت كتجسدش للمتابعين
الجمهور تفاعل مع العمل بشكل كبير لذلك
لناخذ وقفه مع بعض تغريداتهم
[موسيقى]